Mike thanks for joining us so clear this
up with lay beyond bail why would he
come back and play the second half of
the season here's what it comes down to
under the collective bargaining
agreement he has to show up by next
Tuesday to get ready to get credit for
the contract year and that and here's
what that does it forces the Steelers in
Marsh to decide what they're gonna do by
way of franchise tag transition tackle
by DeMarco white because if he shows up
and if he gets credit for this year
under the contract there's no way they
would use the franchise tag on him again
next year because it would be the
quarterback tender of 25 million if he
doesn't show up he's still eligible for
free agency but the Steelers could tag
him again next year at the same number
that they tagged him at this year that's
the difference 14.5 million so they
could just retag him again next year
they could play this out again and the
thinking is the Steelers would trade him
next year so that's the difference and
consider this and let me give you the
best example I can think of Sammy
Watkins remember when he got his big
contract back two guards people like
what the hell it's Andy watch things
done to get that kind of contract here's
what he did he became a free agent at a
time when he's young he's semi
accomplished and you don't have to give
up any draft picks to get it so lady
I'll bail if he hits the market with no
trade obligation if you don't have to
give up draft picks to get him you're
gonna pay him more money and if the
Steelers still control his rights under
the franchise tag at 14 and a half
million which they may very well do
again and then try to trade him that's
the difference between showing up and
not showing up if he shows up he hits
the market and he gets a gigantic
contract if he doesn't show up he's
running the risk the Steelers tag him
again and then they control his rights
and then they trade him to who they want
to trade him to and he gets less money
because whoever he signs with has to
give up whatever it is a second I'll
take a third I'll pick whatever whatever
the team has to give up necessarily is
less dollars they'll pay him do you
think he's showing up I really don't
know at this point I mean look that the
thinking is he doesn't want to subject
himself to injury he doesn't want to do
anything to disrupt the money he thinks
he's going to make X March so if you
show up at all you're incurring and
enhanced risk that you're going to get
injured now with James Connor playing as
well as yes maybe they wouldn't use lady
on bail as much
he feared that he would be used and
that's why he initially didn't show up
for me eight hundred fifty five thousand
a week isn't worth thirty touches per
game because there's a chance I'd tear
an ACL there's a chance that I pop in
Achilles tendon there's a chance I have
a career in to connect injury whatever
it is I lose that huge payday that I
think is out there next March so now
that Connor is playing well and there's
only seven games less than the season by
the time he returns maybe that's when he
says I'll roll the dice I'll take the
money and maybe they won't use me like
they were gonna use me but you know the
only certainty if you're looking to
protect yourself and ensure that you're
a hundred percent going into 2019 is to
not show up and then it comes down to
that analysis of what would a team pay
if they have to trade for you versus
what would a team pay if they can just
sign you on the open market that is the
core question at this point and that's
that's the answer he has to resolve by
next Tuesday
do I want to possibly be traded and get
paid that way or just walk to wherever I
want to go finish this sentence if the
Cowboys don't make the playoffs well it
won't be a coach and maybe Joey Jones
will be I mean I don't know who the
coach will be next we've seen a
rollercoaster affecting Dallas Jimmie
Johnson was fired in 1994 where you know
Jerry Jones wants to run the show and
then he realizes after several years
it's not going well it bottoms out and
then he goes and gets Bill Parcells and
he lets Parcells run the show and then
he gets to a point where hey I can do
this I don't need a guy like for
ourselves and then you go the other way
with Wade Phillips and Jason Garrett so
do the bottom out to the point where
Jerry Jones is willing to ride sidecar
for somebody who comes in and takes over
and and that's really what it becomes
I think Jason Garrett I think at this
point there's so many fans that are up
in arms about Garrett and this
experiment has played itself out you
know where they invest time and effort
early in his career thinking he would
eventually become a Tom Landry that's
not happening at some point you just
have to pull the plug and find somebody
else but that's gonna be the question
Cowboys I think Garrett if they don't
make the playoffs I think they're it's
done the real question is which
direction does Jones go after that why
don't you just go all-in on Josh
McDaniels well look I
well what does always means oh you have
to give me the key to the franchise and
really step out of the way can you can
you trust me he's going to show up yeah
I don't think he ever pulls again what
he did last year with the Colts I don't
think I'll try that card twice in a
career and I think and this is a real
question Dan this may be your poll
question all if you have one yet or not
which job would you rather have as a
head coach the Cowboys are the Browns
right now I'm taking the Browns because
they got bigger be field and I think
that Browns job I think they're gonna be
lining up out the door for that job area
percerin sniffing around and he's
retired
I think there's coaches who are
currently coaching other teams they're
gonna be intrigued by that Brown job
they got two months for this to
percolate before they start looking for
the next head coach there may have
plenty of all they're gonna have so many
options it's gonna drive me crazy to
eventually have to choose one you know
we were debating about having that as
the new poll question of which job is
more attractive the Cowboys of the
Browns and you like Baker Mayfield more
than dak Prescott yes absolutely
absolutely because I think we've seen
Zack Prescott's dealing with Baker
Mayfield I think the ceiling is
unlimited and you know it's that spark
he brings it's the intangibles it's the
leadership it's the pretended miss
and there are a lot of coaches out there
they think it secretly loved may feel
just like last year there are a lot of
guys who were secretly all in on Patrick
mahomes and you try not to let your your
hand be you know revealed so you keep it
quiet but I think any of those coaches
out there that we're all in on bass
field they may be thinking how do I get
my way to Cleveland for uh you know for
2019 and beyond because that's ten years
of successful football for a team with
an empty trophy case Mike thank you as
always we appreciate your time hey it's
Mike Florio pro football talk live on
NBC Sports Network for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
you